was hättest du denn sonst jetzt gemacht
was wolltest du hier überhaupt du hast
mich aus der stadt raus geschmissen habe
ich gehört wie vorwärts bekommt seine
weiter mit dem weg nach tirol day
beendet mit einer gleichen konzentration
take du mit kompakter hu berlin freunde
herzlich willkommen zurück zu minecraft
hier zusammen mit einer geilen
konstruktion habe die konstruktion
gesagt ich weiß nicht ob ich hab
konstruktion also katastrophal für diese
tolle spannende folge heute ja zunächst
habe ich festgestellt dass mein
minecraft sound ganz leise geworden ist
haben diese laut gemacht ich habe vor
ich habe in den letzten folgen du wirst
es nicht glauben ich auf die letzten
zwei stunden damit verbracht meine
kisten zu sortieren
das halten dass man sich auch mal machen
bei mir war epic action und ich habe
letzte folge zander getötet weil erst
jetzt einer stadt pink und alles was
stadt pinkes ist für mich abschaum und
bisschen mit ihm ja auch gekillt gibt
für mich abschauen so ist es hinter
abschaum halten und deswegen weiß ich
nicht also ich würde an sich sonst noch
im haus weiter machen aber wir haben uns
ein bisschen hierüber unterhalten das
können wir jetzt auch für die zuschauer
einmal erläutern was ist mit der
schweinefarm sache ist noch mal was über
1000 gesorgt
also meine damen und herren was ich euch
ja schon mal gezeigt habe hier als mal
halb vier auf zwei wahrheit konnte das
40 herzen
ja krass ey du ich habe auch ein
bisschen aluminium kannst mir gleich
zeigen wie ich das mache na klar okay
verlaufs wall street aber ich hab's
verlieren der folge gesehen ich habe
nein gesagt sondern mir auf den knopf
drücken und dann kann ich eigentlich
auch bei uns kommt nach richtig richtig
richtig viel raus habe ich gehört
guck mal körper hier gucken wir sehr
genau diese tribüne hier wir sehen die
schweine sterben
was soll sie also cash ich habe da schon
mal einer folge bei mir gesagt dass wenn
ich hier runter gegangen und hab gesagt
onlinekäufer die unten die
schweinefarmen machen weil die sollte
eigentlich da hinten hin kommen zu mir
ins haus aber das werden wir dann
einfach mit einem job oder ändert oder
so dann um genau das hab ich also wenn
ich hier unten könnte ich eine ändert
jetzt hinstellen
das heißt wir machen das entweder so
dass ich hier neben der ändert hinstelle
und du dann einfach von dieser kiste
halt in die ändert es rein tun muss und
dann von der ende das heißt genau das
heißt du müsstest auch eine ändert es
sozusagen bei hier in der essensausgabe
waren damit man sozusagen dann auf den
transport machen kann oder was ich mir
gedacht habe ist das wäre aber auch
relativ aufwändig würde ich aber auch
machen wir kein thema das heißt es gibt
so eine hopper konstruktions heißt
müsste für jeden blog ein hopper setzen
und jeden davon mit redstone bauern auch
mit dieser klocke verbinden und das wird
so sein dass es halt darüber
transportiert wird halt nur eine längere
anlaufphase hat zwei wenn du zum
beispiel das anmaßen würde das ja keine
ahnung 50 ticks vielleicht auch weil
dass er 50 werke sind aber sonst ja gut
ok will uns wird da schon etwas
einfallen also was entscheidest du hast
was wir machen
in der kiste einfache variante oder
hopper denn der kiste war besser ich
mache mache ich die fallen nur an wenn
die da mach ich die farben nur an wenn
ich auf dem server bin und dann im am
ende jeder folge nämlich dem euro heraus
und packte dann so eine gemeinschafts
kids daran muss ich etwas ausholen kann
ja auch schön tipp geben und zwar hab
ich mir weil ich jetzt ob es arbeitet
ein ende ab backpack man habe immer
meine männer kiste dabei das eigentlich
auch ganz klar dass neid
was würdet ihr empfehlen ok keine
vielleicht mal nachher gucken was ich
erst mal machen wollte war plötzlich
beziehungsweise weiter anzieht in
deutschland einmal andy weggeschmissen
kennst du hast wenn das handy neben
blicken das ist meistens kommt
ich bin in keiner schule das heißt sie
sind irgendwelche leute wollen dann kann
es aber sein dass der dreh von mir
kommen verspätet bei vorher hab ich dir
geschrieben heftig aufnahme giovanni das
mit sogar schon geantwortet habe ich die
antwort stehen
doch was bietet das weiterklicken dort
lauf guckt mit seiner aufnahme business
wege lieber weggeworfen ja ich weiß
jetzt grundsätzlich immer weg weil
seitdem ich hier so eine neue
konstruktion mit neuen pc ab und so ist
das ganze irgendwie so geworden
der pc war das aber schon zwei monate
sind nicht neu aber seitdem wurde von
dir auch gesagt ja wenn du dein handy
daneben hast dann brummt das so komisch
danke übrigens und dessen was wir noch
auf import werden ich wollte alles ab
ich brauche jetzt erstmal alles ab weil
ich das ganze ding ja ein bisschen
umbauen
das ganze haus ab ja auch das holz und
so alles was jetzt kannst du nachher
wieder es kamen nur aktiviert tatsachen
wiedergeben kev ja ich glaub mir das
dann wieder okay vielleicht sehe ich
auch eine idee für diese bäume und zwar
brauche ich dafür blaue wolle baumwolle
das schöne ist wir haben einen kotten
fällt vielleicht liest daraus kannst du
dir strings ganz schnell machen das
heißt gibt ja diese konnten bälle und
das heißt man kann man klickt er richtig
schnell weil du hast du vier strings
dass er eine rolle
und deswegen musste den blauen farbstoff
besorgen fast ein blauer wolle das ist
was ist denn blauen farbstoff eigentlich
nur ach so das ist das geil weil wir auf
dem motto fake spielen und zwar haben
wir es hier vorne ich kann erst mal nix
können auf jeden fall hatte ich hier
damals und friedhof diese ganzen blumen
hingestellt und das ist keine vanilla
farbe aber hier sind zum beispiel so
blut belize ich bin dir gleich vorbei
die blue belly franzen
sie waren sozusagen noch als gedenk
beigaben am friedhof mit dabei und wenn
du die verkraftet klicks direkt blaue
farbe und die muss auch nur mit wolle in
kraft wie heißen die blue bell ließ ja
ich mache dir das kurze sozusagen als
ich lasse meine für dich damit du selber
oder nicht 50 prozent für dich damit du
auch selber kräften kann man doch das
ist rational
das ist ja geil perfekt weil jetzt kann
ich dir ganz gut zeigen was ich dachte
was wir eventuell für bäume hier die
stadt stellen könnten
genau wir haben ja jetzt diese bäume
wurden glauben leitung gemacht oder so
ich weiß nicht von wem die wohnform
sommer gemacht ich finde die idee auch
eigentlich nicht schlecht nur ich finde
das sollte vielleicht mehr struktur
haben ja ich finde die idee auch
irgendwie man sollte doch mal hier damit
cool aber wenn ich mag irgendwie diese
bäume nicht so gern ich will jetzt
einfach mal gerne einen daneben setzen
wie ich mir das vorstelle sind gerade
nicht immer ganz kurzem weg fliegen hier
mit hier die passenden bäume finde es
wird die richtige helfer folge für mich
ab des kommandos unterwegs das wäre ganz
cool wenn du einfach an meinem haus dann
abbauen könnte
ein bisschen ab ich hole mir nur kurz
mein hammer weil damit baue ich einfach
mal drei mal drei da dies ist gewiss
schneller nicht dass du meine kisten ab
ausland alles was da in diesem radius
steht wird abgeholt das ist klar
soweit ich zeig dir ein bisschen jünger
als ich aber eigentlich ganz schön aus
hier mit dem wasser und dem
unfreiwilligen wasserfall oben vom perm
unter also hier wird die essensausgabe
die ich zeig dir das nachher mal im
rohbau wie das ganze ist also eine art
kontinen ist dein mann so kantine
du kannst ja auch so machen dass man
zuerst eine geile idee du kannst ja so
drop hat oder so an kisten anschließen
und nicht locker sondern diese poppig
hopper die in laos schmeißen die heißen
die den richter
ich weiß nicht genau aber wenn du die
sohin tust dann kannst du da einen knopf
im platzieren
das ist sowieso eine kantine oder so
eine kantine wo das wasser auf den knopf
drücken muss und dann wieder zum
beispiel je nachdem welchen knopf drückt
den steg rausgeworfen wird oder was
etwas das auch cool
doch nicht nur leid mich zu dorf dafür
niemals das glaub ich nicht okay was ich
probiert mal ganz kurz
was hier in der stadt richtig leute ihr
beschwert euch in jeder folge über sich
jeder folge bestand ist leute kev bau
dir endlich ein haus feindlich spiel
unke ist scheiße
aber meine ich helfe die über conti dass
er sich nach ausbauen
ich finde solche aber auch ganz cool
weißt du die finde ich irgendwie cooler
und ich von hier oben gucken alter
gekommen oder ja so in etwa jetzt einmal
richtig weil so hat jetzt noch nicht
überzeugt du der der wird schön ich sag
dir ich mache ihnen wie diese bäume die
hier stehen die sendung komisches klar
das ist irgendwie dunkelblonde so ein
netter ja das ist irgendwie weißen ihm
mag das gar nicht irgendwie innstadt
roche ich die das mega geil aus mit den
bäumen von denen das hat mir den er da
gezeigt aber am wasser farben haben wir
die haben diese per bluetooth oder so
erwartet davon habe ich auch welche aber
ich hab die purple teile und die haben
glaube ich die rettungsteams genommen
und was wir verloren haben weiß ich gar
nicht dass es vielleicht sind sind blau
de la hoya schwanken sehen im nacht die
sind auch ausländer
ja so ist das halt april ist commander
oberes schrottwert complete eventuell
wenn wir nicht ganz irre könnte ich ja
mal probieren hast du obsidian ja
irgendwer von den irgendwelcher von den
diamant kisten da guckt das sind die
bäume die den stadt roth haben die sind
cool finde ich darf ich mich einmal
sexuell beglücken bei den sogenannten
jockey 3.0 ja das macht ihr jeder als
belohnung hosen runter jetzt jetzt hier
guckt man die bäume fertig diese bäume
da sind geil
die daneben steht dieser rote die finde
ich cool weil die liest einfach geil
sind ja und bei uns ist sarah du wartest
du kannst ja schlau sein weil ich finde
der baumstamm sieht scheiße aus wie wäre
es wenn ein fach mit einer schere die
ganz normalen blauen blättern imst aber
diesen baum hier weil das holz haben
fast perfekt zu unserem weg dann ersetzt
du einfach die roten blätter mit dem
blauen blättern
das wäre doch was oder das ist ja quasi
genau das ist ja fast grußwort da kann
man dann auch jeder kann einfach so toll
bauen
theoretisch ja genau aber das wollte ist
echt scheiße aus so wie aber kann aber
jeder weiß was ich meine was ist dein
haus benutzt das ist glaube ich nicht
was wie wo was ja das was bei uns an den
wegen an den seiten ist ja genau
ja genau das sieht geil aus halt ja egal
ich mach das mal einer anderen folge die
zuschauer kann ja auch in die kommentare
schreiben
eventuell ideen habt auch jetzt kann ich
mich erst mal mein haus du kannst dich
aber ruhig um dein haus kümmern
ich bin ich dass du mit ihr die ganze
zeit helfen und rein ich will dir helfen
auf papier ist und nicht und ich will
dass der flame auf mich nieder prasselt
platzes seien kämpfe ich bin es nett was
hättest du denn sonst jetzt gemacht was
wolltest du mir überhaupt du hast mich
aus der stadt raus geschmissen habe ich
gehört
das habe ich nur so gesagt weil ich habe
gerade eben auch in die letzte folge
reingeguckt wo du einfach mal mit einem
komischen deiner app dies passt mit
willigen getötetes wild es hat die
königin getötet wieso fast ich wusste
dass die ab nein sagt wusstest du nicht
etwas salat und vor allem allein schon
hast du den urlaub steckt überhaupt
diese frage zu stellen
ja ich weiß da habe ich mich ein wenig
überschätzt aber du bist auch kein könig
du darfst es nicht bestimmen hier die
könige muss das bestimmt wenn du dich
aber tritten so dass kein stimmrecht
nein die sind in einer stadt
das ändert nichts an der tatsache ich
wieder in einer stadt aber die haben ja
beschlossen dass wenn jemand unrechtes
getötet wird muss der könig entscheiden
das heißt wenn ich glück habe sagt die
app kein thema wenn du glück hast
und wenn nicht dann wäre
immer ganz nrw ganze leben kommt sei
noch nie wieder traf hier
was hättest du denn sonst gemacht war
josef ressel sachen die sind so krass
das ist echt die abgehen was kann ich
sonst gemacht wie meinst du dann werden
wir jetzt nicht helfen würde ist ich
hätte wahrscheinlich jetzt das
transportsystem gemacht dass das
schweinefleisch über transportiert wird
und ich könnte eigentlich dir bei der
cantina helfen dass man da wirklich
sowieso nur art wenn du weißt wie das
dso am tisch platten sind oder so wenn
man dann halt da die verschiedenen
gerichte sozusagen draufstehen das hätte
ich halt fertig machen können dass werke
sehr leicht da machst du das doch eben
weil ich bin jetzt fast fertig mit
meinem haus hier ja ja kurz vor dem plan
arbeit werde nicht was machen ich will
dich jetzt hier nicht aufhalten lassen
einander nicht die glasstadt nicht
klagen ich hab' ich hab ich auch okay
ich hab ich noch gedacht schon
er macht alles kaputt beste so aus
welchem aus welchem holz soll ich denn
jetzt den boden mal bauen
meine ich habe meine fresse wright ace
ist gleich kaputt wieder parierte sich
kann man die reparieren und nicht ihrem
verzauberung / sicher auch schon
probiert so nah gut dies jetzt kaputt
das heißt auch nur neue achse und ich
werde ja nochmal brauchst du eine kiste
die vielleicht platz hat es ist ein
glücksspiel jetzt fast nichts mehr
bleibt ich habe mir ganz viel holz klar
das heißt mache jetzt mal eine kiste wo
ich alles sein was von ihr momentan okay
und wo ist dein workbench die steht hier
steht laut becker
natürlich steht direkt annehmen so ich
muss jetzt erst mal ich habe einen
groben plan davon wie ich mir ein
hausbau es meint auf jeden fall groß ja
es soll cool werden kleiner werden
cool und klein natürlich auch den
münchen gleich mit rein
kein ganzes leben ein verein so
wunderbar weg ok mit dem gesetz das
lagersystem genau ich weitere gar nicht
ich würde das ja damals so richtig
provisorisch und hässlich machen du
musst dir nur sagen wie du das willst
deswegen dass kohl noch mal kurz kommen
könnte ist gleich damit mir zeigst damit
sich vor kurzem haar slap damit ich dir
zeigen kann wie ich mir das vorgestellt
habe
ja was wir auch eigentlich gleich machen
könnten wäre werden du dann das system
der faust und ich brauche ja mal im haus
weiter machen einfach in der nächsten
folge seine twitter fragestunde dann
können die leute wird wollte einfach ein
paar themen schreiben sollte sich gar
nicht so schlecht an
ja hallo mein erster nächsten folge
haben wir noch fünf minuten genau in der
nächsten folge auf twitter frage folge
du bist weiter abbauen ich werde hier
das system bauen genau
vielleicht lasse ich mich ja dazu das
ding ich weiß gar nicht wo ich mein haus
bauen soll
naja das ist auch seine sachen in
unserer stadt ist irgendwie so viel
platz irgendwie aber irgendwie war ich
weiß nicht diese grenze schon ein wenig
ein
magst du bitte komm ja ich bin in meinem
nach fünf blöcke jetzt noch drei so noch
zwei noch ein und jetzt komm ich könnten
ja einfach sagen das ist von wegen so
ist müssen hoch
du bist du der essensausgabe ich auch
absolut ist noch ein zweiter unten
ich bin in der essensausgabe
ich bin mir den schweinen wo bist du ja
ich bin ich bei den schweinen modell ist
die ost insgesamt also wo bist du bei
mir im haus 8 beim aus rein nach vorne
bei der ist noch da steht ein schild
essensausgabe da bin ich da da stimmt
ich aber die essensausgabe eingebaut
würde erstens aufgabe fahrgäste wieder
hier sagt chaco hallo ich dachte mir
man könnte das ganze summe an also
natürlich dann mit treppen die so steg
sind ja ich wollte cooper works stand
zeigte das gleiche erleben dann gehe ich
als wir übrigens unseren weg gemacht so
wie bei den anderen
hier auch mit diesem denken so aber
jetzt habe ich das kann ich dir zeigen
ich zwar meine ich das was kann ich
jetzt so hin bauen gibt das ja so zeige
das so gedacht berichtet als sonata also
dass man hier auch nicht lange ich
wollte ich nicht abschießen
also ich wollte ich wollte nur gegen ich
habe die ganze gegend geschaut und dabei
meine eingeladen so auf jeden fall
erster natürlich dann auch so mit schön
ist dann klosters herunterhängt als ich
dann könnte man den zaun machen oder so
aber dann hier müssten einfach erzählt
knöpfe oder so kann man ihm wieder
borgward knopf an kannst du schalter
daran bauen da oben drauf ja genau den
schalter einmal so hin und herum legt
dann kommt halt gefunden also diese
blöcke werden die hopper sein opfer
kaputt gehen
also da wo das ist wird er nach oben
gucken und da wird das ihm sozusagen
rausgeworfen aber durch die treppen zu
dir geleitet du kannst halt
verschiedensten sachen rausnehmen würde
ich sagen es gibt ja nur zwei gerichte
in der kantine oder fleisch und fleisch
damit keinen unbespielt ankommt für
vegetarier weil einmal durch dann sagen
hier einmal da 1 weil sonst würden die
sich schneiden mit direktion signal
damit sind so gut ich finds gut
ich finde dieses gebäude wunderschön
gebaut der klassiker im ford von mir
dass ich habe die wie die wahlkabine
aber ich dachte okay sagen
gemeinschaftliches gebäude gleich wie
das heißt das heißt drop oder puck
einfach mal ich weiß nicht ob es klappt
oder hopper okay gut oder dispenser geht
ja auch so dispenser schmeißt es raus
das geht ja auch was soll er auch aber
hoppla schmeißt auch raus gehen lieber
dispenser aber dropper der kann es
besser aus als es plötzlich cool an und
hat mehr selben dass ich muss sowieso
gucken weil dispenser der brauch zum
beispiel bögen mit dem drop abläuft das
nicht riskant aber auch mögen ja ja ein
bogen damit halte diese mechanik reinke
wir haben genug er ist kiste voll mit
bögen hast du da oben stehen wirklich so
also dann schaffe ich das mal kurz
vielen beiden teilen aus dann kann ich
dir sage was mache gut mein haus ist
jetzt erst mal grundsätzlich eigentlich
abgebaut
es war klar dass ich das hier nicht so
komplett drauf setze sondern ich mach
hier noch seinen weg zwischen her und
zwar genau hier ist es mit ich ich
glaube das ist sogar mit 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
so natürlich auch mal ein zwei drei vier
fünf sechs bis neun spieler und nicht
wieder erkältet
ja ich hab's schon du bist ganz leider
mussten hier fahren dort sehr letztes
ersten erkältung oder ja weil dann
schneebar dann ist da abgebautes
kombiniert bei dir sowas habe ich hier
noch nie komplett through sport
wir müssen auch gleich wieder die folge
beenden welche das doppelte dieser folge
einmal zeigen ok das heißt ich weiß
nicht welches davon klappen wird
freundlich zeigen euch das auch mal ganz
kurz und zwar hier eine abschneiden des
wegs reinkommen wohl sehr viel breit
sein
also das muss ich mir eben gucken ist
der vier breit
da kann ja nicht sein dass drei breit
hier kommt immer mal wieder kommt es vor
dass freundin ist ja ich bin auf dem weg
also natürlich dann halt woanders die
schalter die wäre ich da noch irgendwas
schön platzieren
also erstmal vom prinzip her ich weiß
ich ja ja ich kann mir das schon
vorstellen
unser hobby hätten über kopf geworfen
vielleicht ist besser umdrehen oder so
ja aber das ding ist er ist die gleich
an den kommerner nächsten folge gucken
wir sind schon über ziehen hier wieder
mal freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann lasst einfach eine bewertung dar
und dann so wir brauchen in der nächsten
folge werde mir dann auf eure fragen bei
twitter ein gehen soll bleibt geilo matt
kuchar